members and welcome to the Development
Committee on the 24th of May 2018 for
our visitors our usual announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the nearest available exit
to the chamber our assembly point will
be in the public car park at the side of
the Civic suite please don't delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please don't return into the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please also note the
meeting won't be audio recorded and if
you have a mobile please put it to
silent thank you
right apologies for absence we have non
so there's no substitute members or
non-members of cat' attending accounts
the mr. high-and-mighty on blank yeah
I'm sorry what happened then
oh dear that's the Hazelwood that's not
sitting there I went for the meeting
right minutes of the meeting hound on
the 19th of April 2018 you're happy for
me to take it sign those as a correction
accurate record of that meeting thank
you declarations of interest counselor
mr. hoi Thank You chairman I hope I get
this right I have a disclosable
pecuniary interests second angel rules
body so the right arm true due to the
proximity of my property for our
property to to the development I will be
I can stay up until the cows to start
their debate and then won't have to
leave Thank You counselor mrs. home okay
thank you that's the Western
okay thank you
any others okay thank you
there is an addendum for item six and
seven can I just ensure all members have
received and seeing that before we
proceed yeah okay right we'll start then
item six which is land between
Windermere Avenue Malians Lane low road
home bridge mr. strengths is going to
take us through this one Thank You
chairman this is one of two technical
applications before you tonight not the
kind of application you see often where
in this case and for that matter the
item to follow we're dealing with a site
that has an outline planning permission
and we're talking about varying
proposals for two or three conditions to
the outline permission members will see
from the report that this site is
allocated from the green belt in the
council's allocations plan for
residential purposes and to bring you up
to speed you will recall that outline
planning permission was granted in
January last year for 500 dwellings and
this is the plan from that outline sites
it was an indicative plan showing the
proportions and massing but one of the
features that the outline sort consent
for members will will be realized that
an outline permission is half a
permission without the detail but you
can ask for access to be considered and
this is the case here you'll see on this
this drawing approved at the planning
application stage the outline stage
around about was shown to form the main
access into the site coming through here
and there was also a secondary access
out through melians Lane up here we're
interested tonight in this roundabout
the county highway authority if we can
look at the approved roundabout detail
please the County Highway Authority
considered this plan this drawing of the
roundabout that was on the other plane
and they specifically asked for a
condition in the consent that this
roundabout be implemented that became
condition a
and in condition 4 of the outline
permission best practice requires us to
list the approved drawings so what we
have is to two conditions condition for
listing the drawings and condition 8 on
the request of the highway authority
that this roundabout be built and as
you'll see the roundabout is about seven
building widths from this property here
and it's a conventional roundabout
something like what we've seen in Hall
Road and braised Lane recently a
standard highways design foot ways
either side island in the middle and
you'll see that lower road runs through
this part here so it's part into the
site and part on the existing highway
now if we can see the proposed plan when
members looked at the reserved matters
which will come before you in due course
but we had a pre appt exercise involving
the ward members members requested that
a bus stop be provided at this
roundabout feature now though that's the
same roundabout you'll see it's in a lot
better detail because this is a what we
call a section two seven eight drawing
the County Highway Authority when they
go to build road alterations etc they
require a lot more detail but the
roundabout is still about seven of those
building widths from that property there
but the difference between the two even
though it's drawn by different people
and agents and looks different on the
plan is this lay-by here that takes the
bus out of the approaching whole bridge
traffic to a bus stop that then leaves
and joins that traffic before going
around the roundabout and continuing in
the the existing roads so that the
material change that's being considered
by members is the bus stop that provided
there which of course makes a change to
the two conditions that we have firstly
the condition for which lists the
drawing and in condition eight that said
you build it build the roundabouts in
accordance with what we was previously
looking at what the Highways Authority
now require is that this drawing be be
constructed under the two seven eight
which incorporates the the bus line so
the nature of this type of application
is that you're not looking to approve or
refuse as such but if you approve it a
revised condition four and eight are
produced correcting the details that the
drawing numbers in particular and a
revised decision notice has to be issued
to the outline planning application
which would incorporate revised
conditions for I am for an 8a as set out
in your report if members were to refuse
this application and disagree perhaps
that the bus lay by the bus stop is not
provided then the existing conditions
for an 8 on the outline permission prove
oh so you're see on the addendum
chairman that the views of the county
highway authority are there they're
informal views sought to us they wasn't
going to comment because this has been
sort of highway driven but to help some
of the comments that have been raised
about proximity and to various features
in the street like the crossings and the
other junctions they've offered us some
detailed advice for members to consider
their members will also say that there's
a further 68 letters that have been
received in objections that you'll see
on the ensuing pages the I can also
advise that the whole bridge parish
council raising our objection to this
proposal members can save from the
informal highway view that the
roundabout design although in better
detail has been safety audited and
accords with the detailed designs and
industry standards the provision of the
bus stop as requested by members will
improve sustainability it will allow
people on the bus to alight and go to
the development that's proposed and the
recommendation is therefore that the
revised design incorporating these
changes on these drawings be worked into
new conditions for a an 8a as set out in
the report thank you
to Houston David was awesome pounds
maximum five minutes I'll let you know
when you got a minute to go good evening
and thank you for hiring me to speak
this evening as you know sort of stated
already planning permission for the the
highway works was was consented in
January 2017 and the application before
you this evening is simply to allow
condition for which lists the approved
drawings to be updated to reflect the
proposed layout and also for condition
eight needs to be revised to reflect the
minor material amendments to the
approved layout which is of course the
proposed bus stop the first bus stop has
been proposed through a process of a
fairly extensive prior consultation with
various stakeholders including the
parish council officers and members of
the district and also Holdridge
residents association we were asked to
provide a bus stop and lay by
effectively as a relocation and upgrade
of the existing which to the south are
watery Lane whether or not that stays in
place in situ is largely up to the bus
operators and themselves I should think
but we will be if permitted be proposing
the bus stop as you see in front of you
it's in all other respects the
roundabouts is as per previously
proposed in terms of its the details
that you see before you there show the
tracking on how vehicles including
emergency vehicles and refuse lorries
etc can accommodate will be the
negotiate whether the the roundabouts
the proposal would have no additional
impact on done did the previous
roundabout proposed on the amenities
which neighboring residents might
reasonably expect to enjoy
moreover the proposal will improve the
accessibility and connectivity of the
development as as proposed as well as
significantly proving the safety for
pedestrians compared to the existing
facilities on offer we also wanted to
make sure that our development is as
sustainable as can be reasonably
possible and the provision of enhanced
public transport facilities will help
address this thank you for your
consideration Thank You mr. hoy Thank
You chairman I would agree that and
we're grateful forum the developers for
listening it to us when we did request a
bus stop there's as as mister has said
the existing bus stop is not useable
effectively and this was a really good
idea when we're pleased they did to move
it to create a new bus stop if you like
I think the only concern I have is that
it has gone before the roundabout not
after whereas I thought the a bus stop
after the roundabout would have been
much better positioned I've got some
concerns around the bus blocking the
view to the right it's a more complex
Junction to the right or to the left as
we look at it but to the right you put
out of the new estate more complex
junctions shown on that map actually
because you have the the junction of all
tree laying with Holdridge Road there
which is now creating a sort of mid slip
road I'm not sure what you called it off
to the right as well and I'm a bit
concerned about the yeah that's a bit
misleading as well because there isn't
around helps if it wall should be laid
on on the far left
that's the roundabout will not be there
so I think that's causing a bit of
confusion
so the
the so my concerns are that the the
roundabout causing disruptions to the
first house as you're coming to whole
bridge on the left and also the the the
positioning of the lay-by if a bus or
two buses could frequently be in the
case or in that bus labor at the same
time blocking the view to the right
where traffic is coming out of all three
lane or around the corner from the whole
beach road that's issued in essence we
asked Rob what would like the remembers
to consider Thank You councillor missus
hoy do you wish to say anything before
we get started the only thing I really
want to say is that you got one manned
about practically on top of Earth
another minivans about which whatever
way you look it is gonna cause
congestion okay we open the debate up
now so I'll just wait for you to
thank you so members we've got what is a
fairly technical item here as far as I'm
reading it essentially it's the
insertion of a bus Bay into the road and
that's the technical detail that we're
looking to consider we have got informal
comments from Essex highways but Essex
highways are the statutory highway
authority so I would caution you if if
you're going to comment on those it
remembers slight anyways on what you
want to say anything is your chance now
that there's only one proposed around
the boat the other one walter lane is
not a roundabout it's just a junction so
really the action we consider you thank
you
that's the Wilson then thank Shevin the
I to welcome the developer listening to
local concerns about the late way and
can I just confirm first of all that the
roundabout hasn't physically moved its
position so in other words it's not
moved further to the east chairman that
is a view that that's been expressed for
number of residents and we've checked it
as best we can obviously because it's a
a better detailed design I'm not saying
there isn't a half a meter one meter
distance when when engineered but if you
remember the plan I first showed which
was the sort of concept layout plan it
showed the roundabout in that position
and it's the same distance from the
house that the previous member referred
to on the Left we've we've been able to
snip that off that it is the center of
the roundabout is in the same position
okay the I actually walk down to Walter
Elaine tonight I measured the distance I
reckon it's 25 meters from Walter from
the junction of watery Lane according to
the scale on the diagram so the entrance
is 25 meters from vehicles approaching
which will be behind the bus watery Lane
is a national speed limit but actually
they've got to give way so they'll be
coming out of watery Lane relatively
slowly however coming north along whole
bridge road and then when it turns round
to the right into lower Road that's
actually a 40 mile an hour speed limit
and so I share counts to the highest
concern about bus is pulling eating and
then not being able to pull out so when
I look at the comments the addendum the
informal comments from Essex alibis when
I say that there's no way that the
proposed bus stop could be moved to the
east of the roundabout the only reason
that they give is that there are
existing facilities available to the ace
of the Ferry Road mini roundabouts
well actually although that's
technically true that's the bus stop for
the 63 bus which only runs very
sporadically during the week and also
limited service for schools so I'm not
really content with the the comments
from Essex heart because they're
informal is there do we know if they
were our standard differences so
standard distances between bus stops in
other words if this bus stop were to be
on all the rather the lay-by were to be
to the east of the roundabout does that
mean that it's too close to the bus stop
is there rules of thumb on this chairman
I can't help you with a specific
specification for roundabouts
unfortunately the job of the highway
colleagues at County but I think if we
go to the informal comments on Essex
County Council we won't be getting
formal comments from them we had to if
you know I prize these out of them in
the run-up to this committee
anticipating members might have some
questions I think they make clear there
that the preference they express but
they've been heavily involved in this
design they they mention the words it's
been safety audited
so their their content the fact that the
bus stop he's off the main line of the
traffic this is where it should go he
goes on to say that about the proximity
of the zebra cross and if it had gone to
the other side of the roundabout he
would be then concerned about the
confusion with the other features that
are further up near near budgets so this
is it seems the preferred location for
the bus stop according to the highways
thank you that cancer stepped out I
think chairman there's lots of
clarification if I may please it's been
touched on with regards to the speed
limit could we see on the drawings where
the 30 mile an hour speed limit finishes
one of the reasons I asked that is I you
commented there the office of commented
there with regards to the design of the
roundabout being that of similar to the
whole road development where it's got
like two levels almost it's got the bit
for the big trucks to go round and then
the bit for the cars to go round is that
the same
and I couldn't work out I'm not a
surveyor competent enough to work out if
there is a change in levels but that red
strip you see round the roundabouts that
we've had built recently which I assume
of a similar design and it seems to show
and in a teluk you can drive over that
as as a car it's it's not a stay off
that red band unless you're a wider
vehicle it just helps in the management
in the psychology the roundabouts but it
looks to me as though this does have an
inner an inner strip sometimes like we
have other ones at the airport they're
banked but I can't I'm not a section two
seven eight office to be able to tell
you whether that is banked I think my
point about it being similar to the one
in Hall Road and the one in braze line
give or take the specifications is that
we've seen these features in the
developments that we've approved
recently and they've said I think
loosely yes it's going to be like the
one in all right but I don't think it
necessary be identical and come back
sure the reason I raised the query is is
if this is on a 40 mile an hour speed
limit we are having problems and
Experian problems in haul road with cars
now transverse in that roundabout at 40
mile an hour because they can do it
because of the design of the roundabout
so I have a concern on that and I would
perhaps suggest that we need to
recommend back to County highways that
if it's not a 30 mile an hour speed
limit it needs to be reassessed and 30
mile an hour speed let me extend it over
it with regards to the bus bay there can
you tell me whether it is a full bus
obey or half bus pay can the bus pull
right off of the road or is it only half
off the road
germán it's my understanding that is a
single bus by I think some of the
members of the public that have
commented have commented about the
provision of two buses not been able to
park in there but my understanding is
that's a single bus that would get in
there it would leave that flow of
traffic gradually into here then from a
standing start would exit like that okay
okay so in other words the bus can pull
fully off of the highway when it's
stopped something okay the other thing
I'm finding very confusing and it has
been mentioned by other members the
roundabout that is shown on some
drawings by the junction of watery Lane
and not on other drawings is that
something that is part of the
development and we're getting that as
part of the 106 or is it just not an
accurate drawing what's the situation of
finding it very confusing where it's odd
so and not the others the Highway
Authority did not want a mini roundabout
in here there's a reason for that they
want to invest in this route out through
the bigger roundabout at the junction of
roth lying and hob Ridge Road which this
application delivers it's not part of
this scheme but it's in the legal
agreement that this being pays for that
what they do not want to do is to
psychologically encourage drivers to go
around the mini roundabout now for water
in line against that public investment
so they are for improvements of this
Junction for right turn capability to an
hour traffic to pass on the inside
towards
they're not stopping this up and
improvements here as you see with right
turn capability slight shaving off of
the highway to make the lanes a little
bit wider and this application will
deliver those changes but they're subtle
changes they deliberately shown on the
approved Rory that's my condition I only
speaks to the knowledge around about
going into the site the legal agreement
then resolves this but because this is
the two seven eight drawing that
highways are working to and discussing
with the applicants
it shows the other works okay can see
Griffin thank you chairman on the
drawing I can't see a bus stop buses
traveling in the opposite direction
going westbound
[Music]
okay thank you okay
that's awesome one more time so it was
just to clarify mr. strange this point
there's actually a bus stop in whole
bridge row so if you come round the
junction it's about 100 meters from
[Music]
we get the gist if you see just where it
says Hall Bridge Road in the first bit
just to the right of it there appears to
be a little bit yeah
it's around about there okay thank you
western Thank You chairman yeah just
another just another point I understand
you're you're doing quite a bit with
that
that's that section I understand it's a
memorial right on that corner is in the
heat going to be your second ever stays
it gonna be moved or if it's gonna be
moved way
thank you chairman just one question of
the officer mentioned been made of the
the bus stop down whole bridge rows
which is going southbound and so of the
alterations to the junction of Walter
alone and low road and Hulbert Road does
that affect that bus stop in any way
those alterations at all
chairman the bus stop one probably drove
down here somewhere the works proposed
we're talking about right round this
corner around here so so I stayed at the
roundabout that we're talking about
somewhere about here loosely the
planning application as I just explained
does include through through the
Greenland's works to improve my wait
terms they are we we care because they
want to improve it but they don't want
to make it preferable to using laws
lying than the big roundabout that will
come so they didn't differently avoided
the round of the mini roundabout
suggestion when the application upon
application is submitted
and they said whether rather have these
right turn featured went we're not
talking about that tonight they're
already approved they're in subject of
an agreement what's happened is the the
roundabout design that they were going
for has had to be molten because of the
request for a bus stop so what that
means is that roundabouts design because
the consent was so specific has had to
be brought back to to change the
planning consent to reflect the the bus
stop provision so because that was
something previously
bring that back to see if you change
thank you okay come back and I just
going back to the bus stop again I
understand what you're saying is it's
big enough of a link for the bus stop my
query you've probably always said this
is the width of the bus because I know
full well when bus is going Spain in a
lay-by they sort of hang out over the
over the side again is the width wide
enough for the bus lecture to get in
there hang hang and it hanging over the
side and have we got a duty of care to
inform the bus drivers or the company
that they've got to go into the lay-by
properly about having to hop out and the
bus will it's all been safety audit but
sometimes I conceived you do get
problems if you're trying to drop down
revised the stop detail in an existing
Street it's just about enough yes you do
get the problems when of course if you
make the provision and a nice wide life
there's nothing to stop the driver for
whatever reason perhaps stopping sure
maybe he's obstructed maybe somebody who
pulled into the bus stop ahead of him
and then drove off sir while he's
alighting passengers he's still stuck
those things about to happen but it's my
understanding this is all
the that that's fine I understand that
question you just so you spilt up when
you said it could be a lorry in in the
in the bus and the bus comes up and it
can't get in properly is there a is
there a way that their signs can be a
sign can be put up side bus only without
I think the grounds of highways
management this is about planning
permission and yeah there's lots of
things we'd say about drivers it would
improve our lives but they're not part
of our decision tonight cancer step toe
you wanted to come back okay thank you
well last time against the Wilson thanks
sure it follows on from the diagram here
I know sounds like a broken record but
the in this is informal comments from
Essex highways and that they're saying
in the third paragraph in the addendum
that the only reason that they can give
for not moving the wrote the lay-by
to the east of the roundabout is the
fact that is going to be too close to
other to other bus stops by having the
lay-by to the west of the roundabout
what you see now it is the point that
counts the Western was sort of alluding
to they've actually got to come out and
cross two lines to go ahead so if you
look there the bus pulls in stops at the
bus stop comes to pull out it's now
gonna cross two lines because the bus
will be going ahead and I just wonder
with the informal comments that he have
they really thought enough about this
remembers what we've got to remember is
that the application before us is the
addition of the bus stop in that
location there's lots of views that
members have got about about highways as
is always the case however we've had
reported that the design has been
consulted as highways have been part of
the consultation and the arriving at
this design in the first place is a
blank canvas and meets only appropriate
standards and in
and comments Essex do say that they are
happy with with what is in front of us
and they are the statutory Highway
Authority so members the recommendation
is for approval with the detail as
printed and shown in front of us can
have those members in favor please
indicate thank you those against okay
that item is approved
our next item is the land is to say same
land in window minute Windermere Avenue
aliens laying low road home bridge
mister strikes is going to present this
one as well thank you chairman
this one is more complicated only
because you'll see on the agenda that
you had we were recommending what it
would amounts in simple terms to a
refusal but who's recommending that the
condition survive but you'll see from
the addendum given the objections raised
by the higher highway authority we're
changing that advice
now as previously relates to the outline
permission that I previously described
it's the subject of condition 38 of that
consent which required the provision in
the reserved matters of a bridal bridal
path now in the pre application process
that we went through the applicants did
advise us that they didn't expect the
county council to adopt the the bridal
path they'd had preliminary discussions
with them about that and we said to them
well that seems okay then if county are
going to not go and support that and
they the applicant would still need to
make a technical application which is
now before you right now to revoke that
condition to do away with it in the
outline consent and the process would be
if you agree that the outline would be
issued - condition 38 so the requirement
would go away members will see the riff
from the report that the bridal path was
required as part of the development van
provisions your allocations document
required a number of things one of which
was the provision of Broadway links and
at the time of writing the report that
you've seen so far until the addendum
the county earth highway authority
advice was not known and officers began
to think well it was a maintenance issue
and the legal agreement that covers the
outline application that makes provision
for the maintenance of the open space is
the foot ways to bridle ways etc they're
all there
covered however members will see that on
the addendum the County Highway
Authority yes they do maintain the view
about maintenance but they do raise an
important Highway safety issue you'll
see that in addition to concerns that it
would attract riders to an area where
there's like no way out other than a
circulatory route which may then force
them on two foot paths to which which
comes through the site and the highway
rules are such that you can't ride a
horse on a on a foot way on a footpath
you can actually walk on a bride away
so it does bring people into conflict
but the the situation is that the
Highway Authority anticipate that by
attracting horses to a suburban edge of
settlement development like this you're
bringing those riders into conflict with
traffic that are associated with all
these households and that inevitably
leads to danger there would be at sway
the outline permission is is written a
separate bride away there would be a
separate track but then there's noise
and disturbance horses or flight animals
and things like this that they say it
just just doesn't work they they require
developments to link one bride away to
another one so you put together the
pieces of the jigsaw so because this
scheme would not connect it would
effectively form a circulatory route to
nowhere effectively they don't support
it not just for the maintenance reasons
which are covered but because of the
safety problems that would be created by
attracting horses to this development so
officers have now had to give that
weight as indeed we're advising you as
members making a final decision to give
that weight and the reason because of
highway safety we have changed our view
to one of supporting the applicants
application to revoke that condition now
if we look at the definitive footpath
members will see that the bridal ways in
the area they're all sporadically around
you've got those around here in this
sort of plot Landy areas we've got our
own public open space Swain Park down
here with a brighter way around it and
you can also ride on byways here at Long
Lane and it bounced Wood Road but you'll
see all of those are connected by
stretches of road here we see footpath
to going through the site the site of
what we talked about with the outline
permission is in here now since we
produce the addendum we have had a
letter of rejection from the British
Horse Society and I'll read that to you
that they identified that when the
outline application was responded to
they cited the need for equestrians and
cyclists in the area the provision was
required as well as general aims of
improving cycling and riding it is
essential in their view for the
inclusion of off-road routes for both
cyclists and equestrians and to stables
links with the bride away network the
they criticize the statement by the
applicant that there is this lack of
connectivity which I'm showing you and
actually go on to say that they are in
investigations as to whether this bridle
weight this sorry this foot way here
could potentially be an ancient bridle
way
but that isn't that hasn't come forward
in the County Council's representations
to us the public rights-of-way officer
through our colleagues at County
highways is very strong about the ayat
the potential for riders to get into
here and then possibly feel obliged to
ride along the foot way network that
wouldn't be true of them all by any
means but there might be a temptation
which would basically be illegal so
taking that together with the main
concern that district officers have
about horses and urban traffic being in
conflict we've changed our
recommendation to you as set out on the
addendum to one of approving the
application by way of not like a
approval and fuser you usually see but
by the accepting the deletion of
condition thirty-eight effectively the
outline permission would be reissued
without condition 38 requiring the
bridleway to be provided i hope that's
clear chairman thank you mr. Harrison's
going to speak on this one again
good evening again apologies I didn't
introduce myself fully last time it's my
name is ray Houghton and I'm the head of
planning for Barrett's at Eastern
Counties this application
as it's been explained relate solely to
the removal of a condition attached to
the outlined consent the proposal does
not relate to the removal of an existing
bridle-path
as none is currently Kani exists nor
does the proposal relate to the removal
of the existing public rights-of-way
number two as we would seek to retain
that unchanged and incorporated within
the wider provision of public open space
and indeed a fully integrated approach
to landscaping proposal seeks to replace
that previously proposed mile path with
a circulatory footpath with connections
beyond the site to increase
accessibility to the wider community
including all the services and
facilities that help which can provide
the expectation that a residential
development should provide a bridal path
where want coney doesn't exist is in my
view unreasonable and entirely unrelated
to the develop proposed in the context
of the use of the valid 'ti of the use
of planning conditions it is unrelated
to a residential development but of
greater concern is the views of County
Council the stylet County highways but
the wider path as proposed would
otherwise be unsafe and is a hazard to
road users simply because of the
conflict I think with horse riders and
traffic vehicle traffic and of course we
we do agree with this view and their
views of the statutory and Council tee
were taken into account all the way
through the evolution of the plans and
this has been going on for almost a year
now and we've always made explicit our
intention to provide a circulatory
higher quality footpath and cycle path
throughout the site
it was an Essex highways suggestion that
we amend the layout to include the
widening of a footpath which on the main
Crescent which is not part of this
application before you tonight but I
think it's important that we show in the
context that an existing footpath will
be widened to become a cycle route as
well so that provides that cycle
connectivity from water from well lower
lane all the way through the site on
Tamale ins road that will be a safer
alternative than cyclists currently have
in negotiating the the van der Vaart for
example at the bottom of Ferry Road the
circulatory footpath as we proposed
would be fully landscaped as I mentioned
to provide an attractive green route
around the site and this would be of
benefits to a wider group of people not
just horse riders but also cyclists and
people wanting to make use of the youth
provision that were providing as part of
the wider application so I ask
respectfully that you approve the
proposal as recommended
so that Highway Safety is upheld and the
design parameters of the approved
outline throughout the pre-application
consultation can also be delivered in
terms of pedestrian connectivity we've
worked closely with a wide number of
stakeholders to ensure the developments
has seen is a interconnected extension
of Hill Bridge which provides access to
high quality open space for the widest
community groups possible thank you very
much thank you again
Thank You chairman um I was in two minds
about this originally and I I was one of
the people who mr. Houston consulted
tonight I I think I said at that point
that I I was in favor of the footpath
since that time I have been amazed by
the number of people within the
horse-riding community who've approached
me about this footpath and right away
and pointed out how key they see to be
within the community obviously living in
hold which we are aware that there are
quite a few horses around we probably
don't really we don't realize it in
relation to other areas it's not
uncommon at all to be driving along the
road to come across horse you see them
down Abbey Road the other day I was
driving a long lower road and there were
some horses three horses going along the
road turning into watery Lane I feel the
Essex highways of this understood the
nature of whole bridge it is a large
system it becomes larger
most people giving they're regarded as a
village and a rural settlement it is in
a rural setting there are fields around
it on three sides with a lot of horses
being kept there is a river to the north
which very enough horses are going to go
in there there's actually a course
carriages further up who who do that
quite well known for horse-drawn
carriages with horses obviously and this
is seen by the horse riding community as
an addition to the bridle way network
just because it doesn't barely connect
doesn't mean it isn't useful and would
and it would take horses off of the main
road network and that's how they that he
they see that and that's what what I
would like the members to think about
tonight
that's the missus hard you wish to say
anything okay this is the last item
tonight so we don't need to call you in
again afterwards that's the Hazelwood
Jewish - yes what I will say is that
under the current law cyclists are not
allowed on foot pause there are huge
amounts of horses riding on public
footpaths together with cyclists which
aren't completely destroying the
footpaths and not allowing the people
who legitimately want to use them
from using them so I wouldn't personally
encourage members to allow horse riders
on this new estate because it encourages
them to use what is there unfortunately
for past - if you don't if you don't
allow horses on this development they
will simply use for part - and
completely destroy it so personally I
think we should encourage horse riders
to go off the main highways onto
designated paths which will be safe for
them unsafe for cars and Nori's because
it keeps them off the main highways as
councillor Hoyer said you look anywhere
in Hockley votes for hull Bridge
there are huge amount of horse riders
and obviously we should be considering
their safety thank you yeah that's the
Western
Thank You chairman I just like to
reiterate reiterate what our councils
have just said yes we we need
bridle-path somewhere other because
we've had accidents on the roads few
months ago there was a young girl got
hoarse got killed she was very very
badly hit by being on the road itself
while she was crossing from one road to
another I'd like to reiterate that we
need some sort of bridle path is there
no way we can go back to the drawing
board and have a look of which way or
how we can help or do this or extend it
I'm not too sure but don't we attract
what might happen just make the point
here that we look at the application
that's in front of us it's not for us to
come up with other ideas okay can't step
toe I think chairman first of all can
you put the site plan up on the screen
for me and can you with your point of
press point out where the existing
footpath runs through the site
so it's basically an extension of that
particular road because the road that's
coming in from the no no no but the
bridleway that was suggested would come
up and join that particular point
yeah okay I'm afraid I'm with other
counselors here I do feel that we should
be providing for the horse fraternity
there is some debate as to whether that
footpath is actually a right-of-way that
will interested see that that pans out
but I would perhaps suggest the
developer needs to consider talking to
the land owner of that particular
footpath and see if I'm create let me
see root for horses and then Lincoln too
so I think I would support retaining the
right away thank you that's the Wilson
Thank You chairman something I've got a
lot of experience not with horses but
we're cycling and it's a similar sort of
scenario where people say well we don't
want cyclists in conflict with other
road use and that's true we don't want
to put horses I'm necessarily in
conflict but as council house said you
go around whole bridge and there are
horses there every day you see horses
going along the byway and they will
interconnect onto the bridle way so I'm
in favor of retaining the proposal for
the bridle way just to give a little bit
of a statistic for this I think any
death on the road is one deaf to many
but in the period of 2010 to 2017 38
riders were killed and 220 horses were
killed so although there is a really bad
statistic this isn't some sort of
epidemic where horses are being and
their riders are being killed all the
time so I think the danger is being
overstated and I do think that I would
move for refusal counts the hoc way
Thank You chairman mr. Franks mentioned
about one of the
a light comment from the hawk society
yeah and they stated that they they had
a belief that that footpath might be
historic bride away they if they
provided any any further information or
evidence to to back up
was like being forced in directly to to
ride on foot lanes that's one concern
but the other concern they have is
introducing bridleway
sorry can come back there I mean there
was an argument about connectivity and
making sure that the brighter ways and
just sort of like to a dead end or just
you know doesn't particularly go anyway
but if that brighter we was connected up
to footpath too and that was improved to
for a false accessiblity it would
provide an appropriate route off the
highway which is still relatively
disconnected around swing path if you go
the other way with these two roads you
come down Blount's wood Church Road up
through folly Lane and then your short
hop again to a circuit arrived
poverty glitz but I think the nature of
the brighter ways are that they're in
fragmented locations connected by main
main roads that the point that the
county of Highway Authority you're
attracting riders to this facility gets
another fragmented location you're
bringing them in conflict with traffic
you're potentially encouraging cancer
Williams Thank You chairman um can I
just have confirmation
this isn't replacing an existing
bridleway this is a brand new bridle way
my concern is horse riders will be
encouraged to use that roundabout to
grain access to it and why this why this
development why do we not have runways
on all other developments just to me I
have to say seems it seems to be it will
create more problems than it would
that's what informed the applicants for
this in the process when they don't
think the highway authorities because of
that risk not just the connectivity but
the conflict
what they're looking for ideally is a
bridle a link that takes horses away
into an environment that's away from
traffic
that's what we're doing here we we've
got a condition that attracts the riders
into an environment where they're gonna
meet traffic yes they would have a
dedicated path riding separate from the
vehicle you're still bringing them into
that location as they get on and off
that half as they cross the streets and
things in the layout if there's that
risk which they must come back then
cannot just reiterate Hawkes is right
quite legally on the roads now obviously
we don't want to go in conflict with
traffic but there's already four
thousand houses in whole breach and this
is only another five hundred so what's
the particular risk for these five
hundred houses having horses riding
around them for the other four thousand
houses in Hill bridge I can understand
why then the knee the the wish for a
bridle path K came in it was open land
it's going to be developed now and
perhaps it was seen as a substitution
for some of the loss of the the open
space that potentially was available and
there were some equestrian activities in
the vicinity but I I I see us having a
wish to promote all sorts of activities
around the the district quite rightly
horse riding cycling walking running the
whole package but I think we do have a
responsibility that was recently a an
event around Hockley woods where some
horses a group of riders took to the
road to try and promote awareness of
riders and horses and how they work
together and it was a good event but
nevertheless it did cause a lot of
problems and did highlight the
particular issues now you're quite right
councillor Wilson that there are plenty
of occasions when horses are on the road
but in terms of the number of horses
that are out there in ownership and
being used
it's relatively few that do venture out
on the road I also do a considerable
number of miles on the bike and you
extreme exercise extreme caution when
you come across a horse I think this
issue isn't so much about our
willingness to support horse riding
wherever it may be I think it does boil
down to the safety issue and having an
encouraging horses into a new area an
urban area where horses cyclists
Walker's families children are going to
be in close proximity you have to put
the weight to the different arguments
and I found this a really challenging
one but on balance I think I'm coming
down on the side of safety and I'm not
I'm not going to be able to support
putting riders in such close proximity
to situations of hazard when there are
other facilities around and I think this
would be not only providing opportunity
for risk but also inviting in from a
wider area the opportunity for risk so
it it's it's a difficult one it's a it's
a balance of argument thing but for me
on balance I think I'm happy to support
the application for deletion one of the
things that what was in my mind was when
mr. Houghton particularly mentioned the
widening of footpaths so it's not just
loss of one facility without any any
recompense we have got some recompense
in that the facilities for pedestrians
and maybe cyclists if you if you cycle
off road or enhanced that's where I'm
live
on this one so you mentioned refused
councillor Wilson I think in this case
if the if the what's before as the
officers recommendation is not accepted
which are our move then the status quo
of the bride or remains as my
understanding as explained I think at
the beginning in this meeting chairman
it's not quite an approval a refusal
situation what you have to think of the
mindset with these is that you're
changing a condition you can say that
the recommendation before you from
offices is the one that's on the
addendum which is that the condition be
deleted but if you were to decide
otherwise the the condition that exists
on the outline is now somewhat
technically defunct because it required
these details to be submitted in the
past so you'll see that the equivalent
of a refusal is the the first officer
recommendation you have which is on the
agenda which recasts the condition to
word it that they would have to provide
these details at a time in the future I
think it may say prior to first
occupation of any dwellings or to allow
them to start working cetera so it
wouldn't be a case as it was on the
first application that if you if used to
say no then the bus lay by and the bus
stop wouldn't get provided would go back
to the drawing that was approved in this
case if you're saying no you have to
have re word condition 38 so that the
requirement of condition 38 could still
be achieved and that is drafted for you
on the first officer recommendation but
just to be clear the recommendation
officers are giving you which you've
discussed I hope members understand
clear is to completely omit condition 38
but the decision obviously is down to
members thank you
so members I'm going to move the revised
recommendation as printed on page six of
the addendum which effectively is
deleting condition 38 which is the
requirement for the bridle-path
okay on happy with what we're voting on
what this means sorry chairman on a
matter of all of there was a proposal we
didn't get seconded but then no second
oh yeah I've moved on so this is this is
where we are now remembers that those
favor those members in favor of the
revised recommendation as are printed on
page six of the addendum please indicate
those against one two three four five
that's okay thank you so the
recommendation to approve the deletion
of the bridle-path is approved and the
other tranche of recommendations is
taken as part of that yeah okay right I
say thank you to particularly technical
ones tonight thank you very much for
your time attendance and concentration
you